Oh welcome to this video demia gee that
sounds we arrived Academy as a Turkish
name at least it's something he's from
Turkey so um actually screwed up my
water I wanted to play a Bishop f4 best
setup but usually I start with the other
move okay it's not a not a huge problem
okay no says stuff I don't know that
okay I hope I'm not getting into trouble
early on here I really don't know that
line because as i said i have feds have
screwed up the move order usually am
playing a different kind of move out
early on but really this is how they
play it okay black is fairly active
still feels weird okay just plays it
like it's common knowledge theory maybe
it is i don't know i have no idea but
some people just blitz out every move so
you don't know if it's actually
something that is no no it's just their
way of playing blitz chess like instant
moves all of the time this is this seems
strange
ok so i could be 30 let's let's just
keep that
yeah always the most aggressive looking
move played very quickly okay it's maybe
not that terrible but it looks strange
so let's take here right when he hasn't
calculated any of that he just went for
the move problem is that if he takes on
a one queen a one his King position is
absolutely awful I mean he cannot take
now Queen a1 is amiss mating him
basically you can take on b5 and just
play this position but still a pawn down
he's not taking that he's not taking
that pawn okay so he's taking the bishop
here so what is this point he wants to
do what exactly take the take this home
and play look d8 maybe yeah okay i can
go okay okay one neglects yeah I can't
play Bishop c4 and just sacrifice that
it's not bad
you know the main danger in this in this
the game is that I'm somehow spending
too much time trying to refute that and
then I'm losing on time so let's play
they started taking it what the heck so
he once say once that counter play I
guess he could have taken play Queen f6
that that was the critical line okay
maybe has enough play with Bishop d
4head that's possible that he that he
gets a gets enough play there yeah very
likely is but it's two pawns so Mookie
to rookie to King king g 2 f 3 and then
I don't really know
f3
hmm I don't really think it's so
dangerous now anymore that's usually the
precise moment where you blunder the
game the moment where you think okay I'm
I'm out of the woods now check let me
think about this for just one moment
he's got Quinn age six this kind of
stuff that's really dangerous am can you
believe it it is somewhat dangerous so
the cookie talking that's not that's not
really ideal King g2 is checking me
I don't know maybe I'm gonna seeing
ghosts that's possible really if he goes
green age six i can go kingi for it's
nothing really bad wrong with that I
think let's just take here I hope I'm
not screw that that would be really
frustrating I mean I in some way i
already have screwed it up because it's
awfully complicated for and it probably
didn't need to be i think it really it
just has a check and I go to reform
I think yes to take we know six check so
can I avoid the Queen trade is there any
point in that i am not sure you can
check him here time morning but i don't
really see how it leads to much check
that King g7 check their King edge six
channels do this that okay then I'm
keeping our all pawns probably the
queenside points I enough to win going
to give form
check
rook t3 is that a defense that's it
would suck rly look III
ok
it could be some kind of weird zouk song
here maybe King f5
b6 takes I can do promote on my own
unfortunately King a fire that's a good
move it really is and then King King f6
and I don't know how I'm preventing them
made what rubbish what rubbish I'm
losing this game on time this is crazy
this is crazy this is this is a total
wind it totally like I can take every
kid tg5 everything win so I don't like a
doll that gets to take you five I found
the absolutely only way not to win this
game b6 they over win yeah now I'd
already got tricky and really get tricky
now it's questionable livid if it's even
if it is still winning I really thought
everything went so didn't didn't look
that closely yeah it's useless
journalist really everything wins I can
also just take this this is the easiest
why didn't I just take the pot the
problem was those meeting threats at the
at the edge of the board I mean I've got
three pawns for the exchange I can just
win with with the Queen side yeah ah it
shot it play aah chak and that after
this it's it's very very about the only
way that that's probably the only way
even this it's still winning this
position probably and
and I'm running here not sure maybe
maybe he can draw it it's it's a tricky
business what is the engine giving 1.5
that's not very conclusive probably
winning but this is now yeah and I lost
some time yeah is it still draws it
still draws yeah I really sometimes
sometimes I should be should just maybe
switch to checkers or something crazy
and after that game that was a I mean
what the heck did he do in that game I
mean beyond words just dashing out some
playing some stuff that was not working
in in the slightest yeah anyway Yahoo p5
is the best move it just Jess it's
nothing ready to discuss them Jeff
anyway wow thanks for watching